du pib franck a un sale boulot ils tuent
des gens pendant trois heures et demie
ce match où nous raconte sa vie yaourt
avec robert de niro dans le rôle titre
dia rachwane est une véritable bombe
cinématographique de fabre basé sur des
faits réels ce film de gangsters est une
incursion dans la mafia italo américaine
de l'après guerre joe pesci et enlever
tutelle incarne le départ est notoire
qui recrutent un ancien combattant
pacino interprète jimmy hoffa un
puissant dirigeant syndicaliste qui a
été condamné pour fraude et conspiration
à 9h10 à grands coups d'effets spéciaux
le réalisateur martin scorsese et à
faire rajeunir de niro quito pesci et
pacino
certaines scènes sont inoubliables comme
celle ci n'était choses plus cher et
nous aidons droit non
morton squeeze a toujours été fasciné
par les gangsters qu'on pense à ses
débuts avec les rues chaudes ou encore
au célèbre des affranchis son film les
infiltrés avaient récolté quatre oscars
permettant d'associer de vous fouillez
dans dia rachwane le réalisateur se
surpassent ce film hors norme sur le
bien et le mal et la synthèse du
meilleur de son cinéma
netflix a gagné le gros lot en achetant
ce film qui avait été rejeté par les
studios paramount à cause de son coût de
production
ce que fait finalement n'être les 6 10
ans nous 160 millions $ à mériter ça
nous gêne pas que faire un flic très
clairement c'est un petit force dire
voilà nous c'est jamais que de la roche
de l'argent de poche on va imposer nos
règles on va aller là où l'industrie du
cinéma plus l'audace d'aller netflix a
un budget annuel de 15 milliards de
dollars pour la production et l'achat
d'émissions et de films avec dia
reichmann l'année 2019 pourrait marquer
un tournant c'est leur vaisseau amiral
pour les oscars dia rachwane débarque
vendredi à montréal dans deux salles de
cinéma seulement
puis à la fin du mois sur netflix ici
louis s'est lui-même radio-canada mots
rien